yo fastest thing alive here to introduce  you to Knight Rider  I am the Dark Knight I said Knight Rider  not Dark Knight this is Michael Knight a  young loner on a crusade to fight crime  with help from the folks at Knight  industries I've got a really cool jacket  and a talking car hello sonic this speed  machine is the knight industries 2000 or  kitc if you prefer KITT was built to  pack some serious power but he still  needs a good mechanic every now and then  thank you mr. Baracus hey now that you  got some fresh wheels let's race where'd  everyone go Michael and KITT are like a  spindash to all sorts of bad guys  including some dark doppelgangers gotta  love dark doppelgangers shadow last one  there's a rotten egg man and the winner  gets a chili dog by the beach I love the  beach really slow mo come on bro gotta  go fast  don't worry I'll catch up  [Music]